justin bieber donated and signed his  personal hockey stick for auction to  benefit the manchester bombing victims i  just want to take this moment to honor  the people that were lost or that were  that we're taking we love you so much  the families we love you so much  after fighting back tears during ariana  grande's one loved manchester benefit  concert Bieber skated with the  Manchester storm ice hockey team on  Monday a spokesperson for the team tells  eg the signed hockey stick will be  auctioned off online after the game on  Saturday proceeds will go to the British  Red Cross and the we love MC our fun  following the bombing in Manchester on  May 22nd that cost 22 lives Margo Haut  [Music]  put your hand up if you're not gonna let  go  [Music]  [Applause]  you